so just to get us back up to speed where
i left off in the last video
we have a bank
that's sitting on an asset that maybe
originally paid a hundred dollars for
let's say it has for sake of 60 of
liability
60 of uh forty dollars of equity that's
when they paid for it so this is a
hundred
this is sixty dollars of debt
and they had forty dollars of equity and
these are the toxic assets we're just
assuming a world that you know it only
has one set of assets and the problem
that we said from the beginning of the
banking crisis is that the banks can't
sell these assets to pay off its
liabilities as deposits or other uh
debtors
for the price that it wants to sell them
at that the banks are only because
obviously if they sell this for anything
less than 60 dollars the bank is
bankrupt right so the bank wants to sell
for so this is the bank wants to sell
for greater than i'll say 60 i won't say
60 cents on the dollar but it's the same
thing wants to sell for greater than 60
dollars while the market
is is willing to pay less than
30 for this asset and obviously if the
bank went and sold this at the market
price and only got 30 dollars for this
if this whole thing became 30
then the debt the liabilities become
worth much more than the asset than the
thirty dollars and the bank is bankrupt
and so as i outlined in the last end of
the last video with the the current
incarnation is for
you have a public private partnership
where you have let me draw their equity
let me try to draw it a little bit
better so let's say that you have
i'll do the numbers slightly different
so you have five
dollars five dollars from a private
investor
is a review of the last video you have
five dollars from the treasury these are
both the equity investors
and then you have fifty dollars borrowed
from the fed and i'm doing this a little
bit differently so the numbers match up
exactly with what they're going to pay
for the asset
so you have fifty dollars
let me see so if that's ten fifty would
be something look like something like
that
so you have fifty dollars that you
borrow from the treasury
oh sorry from the federal reserve
from the fed reserve
and so this entity will have sixty
dollars here
when it gets capitalized
do that in green
sixty dollars
and what they can now do is they can
give that sixty dollars to the banks
essentially paying a price that the
banks are willing to part with the
assets for and then the banks are going
to give them the asset so now the bank
has a hundred dollar or has sixty
dollars of cash that it can use to keep
its liabilities liquid and now this
entity right here has a you know a toxic
asset we could call it
and i addressed it in the last video if
you know why is the investor doing this
because they shared disproportionately
in the upside right they paid 60 for
this thing and this is a real quick
review if this thing ends up being worth
let's say it ends up being worth a
hundred dollars
then they owe 50 to the federal reserve
right that's this loan right here to the
fed and then they split the equity with
the treasury
right so how much equity there's a total
of
50 of equity left 25 for the treasury 25
for them
for the private investor
so their initial investment
was five dollars
and it went to 25 right that's awesome
five times your money
and then the down case
what's their down case their down case
is let's say that toxic asset really is
worth thirty dollars right so let me
draw that and this is a review of the
last video
it's important because it really bears
into you know what might happen
so
let's say that this is so this is
optimistic
this is pessimistic
so let's say these assets end up being
worth thirty dollars then you have this
fifty dollar loan from the fed
and you have no equity left over and the
fed essentially is left taking a loss on
its loan but the private investors since
there's no equity is going to be left
with zero so you're you went from
five dollars
to zero but this is still a pretty good
risk reward i mean depending on how you
weight these probabilities but a lot of
people you know if you thought that
there's an equal chance of this and this
happening
you would take this bet if you had a 50
chance of of making you know five times
your money and only a 50 chance of
losing your money i mean the expected
value here is it would be 0.5 times 25
plus 0.5 times 0. it would be a 12
expected value right
so i would pay 5 for something that has
a 12 expected value that's a great
return you're making 200 and you're
making 140 on your money i mean that's
you don't see returns like that every
day unfortunately the probability of
these two things happening aren't
equally likely
because obviously right now the market's
willing to only pay thirty dollars for
these things right the market i mean if
they thought that the the if they
thought there was any chance that these
things were worth more than sixty
dollars any chance they would be trading
at higher than thirty dollars so given
where the current market is before
government intervention clearly no one
thinks that they're worth
that there's a really good chance of
them being worth 60 there's much there's
a much higher probability of this
of this scenario occurring than this
right and you could do a spreadsheet and
you could weight the probabilities and
if you make this probability high enough
relative to this one then of course
then the expected value is still going
to be less than five dollars you're
still expected to lose money and so you
might say well who would be who would do
that even though you know paul krugman
is out there saying you know this is one
of those tales um you know heads i win
tails you lose type of scenarios and
that is true
in the positive scenario the private
investor makes
the the bulk of the money alongside the
treasury with the fed just getting a
very low interest rate back on this
money
while in the negative scenario most of
the hit is going to be taken by the
federal reserve with their loan and then
the treasury who's an equity investor
alongside them right so that is one of
these things that paul krugman is
talking about but i would say that you
know even if that an intelligent
investor just because the the risk
reward is disproportionately weighted to
the other guy they still wouldn't want
to invest it if this is the more likely
scenario so the question is who is going
to do this and this is kind of what i
mentioned the last video could be
troubling
the obvious thing is that the banks
might want to buy it from themselves so
let's let me draw everything because
this is an important point to make and
frankly i don't know how you can prevent
this from happening if if this
version of geithner's plan ends up
passing so this is the the bank's
balance sheet
kind of their before balance sheet
let me say they paid 100 for these
assets
they owe 60 all liabilities deposits
whatever and you know originally they
have 40 in equity
what the bank does is it takes some
extra money and you know they could take
they could raise equity or for all we
know they could raise money i mean the
government is giving them loans right
now this isn't a this isn't fiction so
what you do is
you borrow
let's say you borrow
seven dollars from the government right
and this is happening i mean the
government is giving loans to these
major um these major banks to citibank
and
and banco mayor et cetera and they'll
get seven dollars of cash
right here
right
now what the bank does is they create a
separate entity you know they could call
it whatever they want they could put it
in a hedge fund to do this i mean banks
are great
special purpose entities happen all the
time and there's nothing to stop a bank
from putting this seven dollars into
another entity
right another special purpose entity
where the bank essentially owns the
equity
and this cash went to that and then
taking this seven dollars
and using this to participate in the
plan
right
in this new geithner plan so the bank
takes that seven dollars that they
essentially might have just borrowed
from the government participates in the
plan as the private investor
and i'll put that in quotes and they
could put a bunch of layers here and
obfuscate it or even get one of their
hedge fund clients to do it you know by
giving them good terms on something else
i mean there's a million and one ways
you could you could set this up and
that's why i think it's impossible to
legislate around or legislate to prevent
it so they do that there
the federal reserve or the the treasury
will participate
side by side as an equity investor and
then they'll borrow eighty six dollars
from the federal reserve
eighty six dollars
from the fed
that's from the treasury
and now the bank is essentially the
private investor right they're
controlling this entity here they're
controlling entities that control that
empty it doesn't matter
but they
they essentially set the price for which
this entity is going to pay for
its own assets so they could they could
give they could pay a hundred dollars
for this thing even though everyone
knows that these these things are worth
nowhere near 100 so they pay
a hundred dollars for this take it off
their balance sheet and then they're
sitting with 100 cash and this is a this
is sitting there with a toxic asset why
would a bank do this well think about it
in this reality before any of this
happened the banks had a hundred percent
exposure to these toxic assets right it
had this this whole thing right here
it had exposure to and for all we know
that they're only worth thirty dollars
but the bank never wanted to accept that
reality
while in this reality the bank only has
seven dollars exposure to it so even if
this thing ends up blowing up
who's going to take the loss the bank's
just gonna take a seven dollar loss here
and then the rest of the loss is going
to go to the taxpayer the treasury in
the federal reserve so this is an
awesome situation because in this
reality when there was a in this reality
when there was a hit if this was worth
30 the bank would have to take a 70 hit
while in this reality if this toxic
asset now is only worth thirty dollars
the bank's only gonna take a seven
dollar hit and the bank is going to stay
solvent right so this this investment
right here is going to be wiped out
right but still the bank got a hundred
dollars in cash so my fear is
and you know frankly since there's
nothing to prevent it
it's almost a a self-fulfilling prophecy
that's going to happen you know you have
this big question mark
why would a private investor ever
participate in this right
you know even if the government is kind
of giving you more of the upside than
the downside it you wouldn't participate
if you thought that the downside
scenario is more likely but you would
participate in it if you were the actual
seller of the security because if you
are the seller of the security you are
citibank you're going from 100 exposure
sorry you're going from 100 exposure to
only 7 exposure and you're going to be
staying solvent but the net effect of
this is that the treasury and the
federal reserve is writing a you know
they got a hundred dollars for something
or i guess if you take out the seven
dollars
they essentially got ninety three
dollars right
because they had to spend seven dollars
to make this thing happen but they got a
hundred dollars so they spent ninety
three dollars
for they got ninety three dollars for
something that's really worth thirty
dollars so the difference the sixty
three dollars it would be essentially be
a check that's being written from the u
s taxpayer to these banks and in the
magnitude that we're talking about it
wouldn't be a 63 dollar check it would
be a 630 billion dollar check so to me
this would be kind of the biggest
travesty of capitalism and it would be a
a sad day for um you know it would
frankly just make the aig bonuses look
trivial the right answer is you take
that 630 billion dollars
make
take the banks make the banks wipe out
the shareholders and then you
recapitalize the banks with the money
and then you start instead of writing
the sixty three dollar or the six
hundred thirty billion dollar check
directly to the management and the
shareholders who got us into the mess
you essentially recapitalize in eubanks
and i you know i've written a paper
about that and there's a new bank plan
and distribute the shares to the
american people and you get the same
effect without this hugely negative
repercussion of writing a huge uh
providing a huge wealth transfer to the
very same people who got us in the mess
anyway i hope people kind of get on the
story because
it's gotten me pretty troubled anyway
see you soon